on peut quand même dire que c'est très
difficile pour tous les gouvernements de
tous les pays même en allemagne qui
était montré comme un exemple maintenant
elle vit des moments difficiles c'est
une épidémie qui surprend tout le monde
il ya aussi une certaine forme d'orgueil
de la part des gouvernements de penser
qu'ils vont réussir à maîtriser une
épidémie c'est toujours très difficile
c'est donc si dental ils ont eu moins
d'orgueil en asie par exemple
oui c'est vrai c'est possible oui après
c'est vrai qu'il ya eu beaucoup de là on
peut pas le nier et il ya eu beaucoup
très souvent des défauts de
communication et ce qui est vraiment
dommageable parce que la communication
c'est plus facile il n'y a pas besoin
d'argent il n'y a pas besoin de
connaissances il ya juste besoin d'être
transparents honnêtes et aussi un peu de
d'essayer de d'enthousiasmé les foules
et de leur dire ça va aller on va y
arriver on a par le discours sur la
guerre qui était presque trop pour le
coup on n'a pas eu vraiment le sentiment
d'un gouvernement qui était auprès des
français qui allait on n'était pas
ensemble quand on avait toujours
l'impression qu'ils aient tous qui nous
enchante ils disaient qu'on vous ait pas
ce qu'il fallait enfin donc voilà ça
c'était je pense que c'était un des gros
défauts finalement le le bilan le plus
dur je trouve que c'est celui là plus
encore que sur la logistique parce que
finalement on finit toujours par se
rattraper aujourd'hui on est un des pays
qui fait le plus de tests on a quand on
compare avec la grande bretagne où c'est
très difficile de se faire tester ou
c'est pas gratuit
voilà c'est quand même remarquable en
france on peut plus se faire tester
quand on veut ça c'est très bien et je
pense que sur la vaccination va y
arriver mais sur la communication c'est
vraiment regrettable surtout que je
pense que c'est parce qu'il est plus
difficile
[Musique]